peptides just means a chain of amino
acids
um but let's just get this um out so
because there's a lot of interest in
this now
um right you need to sleep exercise good
nutrition uh good social interactions
you need to do all that stuff right
you're never going to optimize
testosterone muscle fat loss Etc if
you're not doing those things you need
to everyone needs to do that then
there's a question of like
supplementation and there are some good
supplements that are legal things like
Tonga Ali fedogi aggressives they can
boost testosterone somewhat
um and that people get benefit from and
don't shut down your own testosterone
production or growth hormone production
then there are drugs prescription drugs
like growth hormone testosterone that
people use for testosterone replacement
therapy and then just all out steroids
like Anadrol Ox angelone where like you
see the guys you know the look right I
mean you know yeah
um you know and that can be abused Etc
any of those things could be abused but
but there's this new kind of wedge in
between supplements and prescription
drugs that are called peptides and
they're a bunch of different kinds and
the ones that are most popular right now
in health and fitness it for use in both
males and females are for instance
things that stimulate the release of
growth hormone they're called
secretagogues that sounds like synagogue
but it's secret agog things like
sermoreline
they all you take it as an injection
they can be bought without a
prescription or with a prescription we
can talk about what's better
um and they're taking before sleep if
you haven't eaten anything for a couple
of hours they stimulate massive growth
hormone release igf-1 Etc they help you
recover faster fat loss muscle repair
they also stimulate libido pretty pretty
this is America yeah what is this sir
morellin why are we not all how can we
well okay a couple of reasons one to get
it really good sermoreline in your
prescription but there are lots of
doctors that will prescribe work on that
yeah what if I'm trying to have a baby
does that [ __ ] that up it does not
disrupt so testosterone will disrupt
sperm production you can offset that so
let's say you were to take testosterone
um it would shut down your own sperm
production testicle shrink some people
more than others but some people will
take HCG human chorionic and additropin
that can stimulate the testes to
continue to make sperm HCG incidentally
used to be now they make it in a
laboratory you inject it used to be
um collected from pregnant women's urine
so in the bodybuilding Community people
used to live really like try and drink
pregnant women's urine there was a black
market for it yeah I knew that yeah I
figured that story was going to widen
somebody
um but did you notice I went in yes
exactly so people can maintain fertility
on uh testosterone but sir morellin will
not disrupt fertility
um why wouldn't you take it okay well
there is this issue that first of all
you need a prescription to get it clean
there are sources online where you can
just buy it without a prescription it's
a little sketchy you go to these sites
and they're like they say venmo me but
venmo me under this name so it's kind of
gray Market the problem with those is
you don't know about the Purity you
don't know if you're getting what you
think let's assume that we have some
connections we can get MDS will
prescribe us for Moreland yeah I've used
sermoreland before I actually still
listen I'm really open about this
because I never want to be like a Natty
or not video on me I'll just say like
not you know I mean not meaning I'm I
take some Moreland about three or five
nights a week
um helps me get into really deep sleep
quickly you get a bit of a IGA F1 boost
it's great you recover I never recovered
very quickly from exercise I didn't
start until I was 45.
um you look great now you look like what
I thought Lance Armstrong would look
like with the steroids
I ride a bicycle but not like him
um uh there's another joke there but I'm
not going to make it what is that no no
no no no no no
um I had to be careful
um I never met Lance I'm sure he's a
nice guy there's a guy who eventually
eventually came clean about his and
people still seem to like him they don't
wear The Wristband though it took a
while but wristband's gone yeah we came
around yeah instead of Live Strong and
sort of like live honest and by not
wearing The Wristband yeah sorry Lance
um
okay the downside is it causes growth of
all things right so if you have for
instance a small cancer growing on your
pancreas it will accelerate growth of
that cancer now so you tend to want to
cycle these things doing infrequent use
you know five nights a week or three
nights a week or occasional use
you know look I'll tell you right now a
lot of the bodies you see in Hollywood
films
are on peptides because right now the
look isn't really super huge oh like 80s
professional wrestling yeah the look is
you know the women are a little bit
leaner and stronger than in past years
the men are sort of in that middle range
you know it's more about definition and
you know okay
um sir Moreland then there's also
something called bpc157 which is
actually based on a gastric peptide
turns out that there's a gastric peptide
that we all make that can promote
healing of tissues and I've talked to
Joe a lot about this they're not a lot
of data on this whereas there are a lot
of data on sermorelin but bpc like I had
a L5 compression and I was always like
in pain standing up from a dumb thing I
don't deadlift anymore I just made a
dumb mistake
um in terms of form and
massage Heat their electric therapy the
whole thing two injections of bpc157
look if it was Placebo okay I'll take it
gone gone BB and the bbc157 is
remarkable a few years ago a guy um tore
his Achilles right before the Olympics
came back
bbz157 was implicated in that so again
you want to get good clean sources there
are Physicians that will prescribe these
again these aren't going to shut down
fertility or testosterone production
um and then there's kids wonky or
anything like that not that we are aware
of not that we're aware of your kids are
going to be okay your kids are just
gonna have so much fire in them you know
what I need to take something so I have
someone to blame it on when my kids
you're going to raise them in New York
it was not peptides yeah you're gonna
raise them in New York I hope I don't
know you know we'll see I think it was
the late Philip Seymour Hoffman that
said in his will that his kids wouldn't
get any money if they lived outside of
New York or Chicago or London because he
wanted their brain to develop in a
sensory Rich environment is that where
he grew up because I'm going to raise my
kids in a different place
no he he unfortunately tapped out
through unfortunate circumstances but I
think there is something having that
intensity you know I mean kids from who
aren't from New York they come here and
they hear a siren go by and they're like
you know my niece grows up in a big city
and she's like totally comfortable in
noise and Chaos she's super calm I see
the kids here they're just like whatever
you know it's like they just can cope
you take a kid like that you put them in
California and they're going to run the
company yeah because there's just they
have so much energy and so much force
yeah you know and everyone else is like
dissolving into a puddle of Tears
because it's so much we're staying here
all right um so okay so there's BP's
there's sir Moreland there's bpc157
there's and then there's this whole
landscape now of like tb500 Etc there's
a lot of kind of um cocktails of
peptides I know less about that
um and they're far less data on that now
as long as we're having this discussion
because of this audience I have to
assume has heard of trt and testosterone
replacement there's a lot evolving there
I'm hearing about guys going on really
young I really worry about that because
it will shut down your sperm production
unless you won't be able to conceive
kids unless you're doing something to
offset that like taking HCG and that
should always be done with a doctor the
new way of doing this is not to get one
shot every two weeks of massive
testosterone but taking smaller doses
every third or fourth day dividing that
up and then doing the HCG as well that's
very common but trt you know the r is
replacement therapy and the range of
testosterone is really Broad and I what
I would think I what I think guys should
do is I started weight training when I
was 16 started I was running and weight
training and then when I got to Santa
Barbara I was more like weight training
and hanging out a bit and then I got
serious about studies but the point is
that you want to train on your own
hormones get learn good sleep good
nutrition good habits and also live your
life right you're not gonna like not
have a beer or two every once in a while
at age 22 just because you might not
recover as well like okay if you have a
tendency towards alcoholism be careful
but you know let's live your life is my
my uh stance but once you have all those
things in place
let's say you already have kids and
people are feeling tired and more
sluggish than testosterone replacement
therapy can make sense for some people
the problem is a lot of people think of
a little less good more is better and
that's not and that's not good and also
it's what you do with that you still
have to run eat well yeah you know
preserve your cardiovascular health yeah
it doesn't replace those they still need
blood work to make sure your prostate
antigens aren't going crazy and stuff
like that yeah I hear about young guys
who are just like you know they're
slamming Viagra and testosterone it's
like this and that that's not gonna play
out very well over time right like see
what you can do naturally with hard work
and dedication and balance yeah and then
over time you can explore things but the
peptides are interesting they're kind of
a you know Middle Ground where you're
not risking as much in terms of
long-term fertility issues
um they're not going to they're not
going to give you a ton of acne or
something or you know make someone look
crazy
um like they could if they abuse
steroids and women are using them a lot
more now because they're milder they
don't have these so-called androgenic
effects they're not going to deepen The
Voice they're not going to create facial
hair for women that kind of thing but
yeah they certainly work they're
abandoned sports for a reason
although last night
I don't want to get beat up by any of
the MMA trial but I can look at some I
mean some of the athletes are either
genetic freaks or they're using in the
offseason I mean I think I've seen some
photos of Conor McGregor now I mean he's
big yeah he's big so either he has
ridiculous genetics yeah or he's on
something listen no shame in that I mean
it's his life he can do what he wants
yeah
um you know there's a runner who ran for
Stanford I think still holds the
American record for Marathon for fastest
U.S Marathon Ryan Hall he was like a
stick finished running got out started
lifting weights he's a beast looks like
something out of a Marvel movie really
mostly because he's just eating and dead
lifting and squatting now he still runs
a little bit but he's not running yeah
gazillion miles a week yeah yeah dude
yeah so the peptides are interesting but
make sure you get a clean Source there's
some good sources like tailor-made you
need a prescription is a good Pharmacy
for peptides these are cleaning because
you don't want to go to where the guy
you get yours from yeah I mean I can I
can definitely I mean I mean I can give
up I mean listen there there is a
physician who's doing this kind of work
online
yeah but and it's not illicit you know I
mean he'll make you do blood work and
that kind of thing yeah but I'll do I do
take sermoreline about three to four
nights a week you can't take it every
night because it has less of an effect
um now and then there's this whole
landscape of gray Market in the old days
we're not doing that [ __ ] yeah in the
old days it was the big drug out here
um in the club scene was GHB gamma
hydroxybutyrate which increased growth
hormone that's what River Phoenix that's
the date rape drug right uh that's
Rohypnol Rohypnol yeah isn't that GHB
GHB uh no GHB stimulates growth hormone
release it's a hypnotic and it was big
in the club scene and then it became big
in the kind of sex club scene
um and then when River Phoenix died it
became implicated in that and they
actually used to be able to buy it at
GNC get the [ __ ] yeah but not anymore so
they but it turns out River Phoenix you
know sadly had a heroin cocaine
marijuana alcohol
um and GHB in his system which is
obviously you know very you know is that
poppers what's poppers uh poppers I
think were something of I don't know you
know what the two drugs that totally
disappeared are are Quaaludes and
poppers yeah quailers are gone Quaaludes
I don't even know what a quaalude is me
neither but it looked fun in that
actual finite supply of from Wolf of
Wall Street which I rewatched recently
great movie but they're they're gone
because people just took them all and it
was supposed to I think help you sleep
or something but then I found out if you
stayed awake past a certain point you
got super high and it got fun that
sounds like GHB and remember ketamine
used to be a recreational drug right um
yeah all these drugs that listen if
people are gonna exploit with a medical
doctor I'm not saying that to protect me
I'm saying that to protect you being in
the audience like you have to these are
not things you want a cowboy especially
with all the fentanyl stuff happening
now is is so crazy I mean you just die
the first time that just yeah because I
remember growing up they said if you
smoke crack once you're gonna be
addicted for Life remember that was the
public message
um
it does seem like you can die from
fentanyl first time
yeah yeah sorry to go dark there but
always happening to a bunch of comedians
yeah yeah really yeah yeah is it true
that comedians they thought there was
cocaine is cocaine in the comedy scene I
think it was huge in like the 80s yeah
and I think for sure it's still a little
bit more in LA and stuff like that
cocaine is just like uh or it was before
this fentanyl stuff it was just a
recreational drug I was surprised
I mean I'll be honest especially like
younger people how often they were using
it it was just like every weekend it was
like smoking weed drinking alcohol I
feel like when I went to college there
was some people smoked some pots maybe
some psilocybin use but it was really
just alcohol yeah it wasn't for Santa
Barbara it wasn't a big um cocaine scene
or heroin scene I'm sure there were
pockets of that but I was never exposed
to that
um well yeah I think that the the
peptides thing is interesting